The checkbox example demonstrated how
ARIA modifies the semantic information
of an element on the page.
ARIA attributes can be used in a number
of ways to augment the existing ways
we can express semantics in HTML.
Firstly, as we saw with
the checkbox example,
ARIA can add semantics to an element
where no native semantics exist.
Such as a div element
which explicitly and
deliberately has no native semantics.
ARIA can also modify existing elements
semantics within certain bounds.
For example, I might use
a button element to implement
an on off switch type of control.
I can add an ARIA role
of switch to the button
to more accurately
express its semantics.
One quick note, that switch role is
part of the forthcoming ARIA 1.1 spec.
So as I'm recording this,
it's not quite ready for prime time yet.
Just like all web standards,
ARIA is moving and
evolving to keep up
with new UI patterns.
ARIA can express the semantic UI
patterns which don't exist in HTML.
This is where ARIA really
comes into its own.
The checkbox example is
really reinventing the wheel.
It's probably more work to create
a fully accessible custom checkbox
then to add custom styling
to a native checkbox.
But in many cases, ARIA allows
us to create accessible widgets
which would not be
possible using plain HTML.
This example shows a tree widget which
we could hypothetically create for
navigating this course.
We can take an unordered list and
add ARIA roles of tree, treeitem, and
group and add ARIA-expanded attributes
to express the semantics at this widget.
ARIA can add extra label and
description text, which is only
exposed to assisted technology APIs.
For example,
if I have an image only button
which doesn't use an actual image
that I could put alt text on,
I can use ARIA to provide
an accessible label for that button.
ARIA can also expressed semantic
relationships between elements
which go beyond standard DOM parent,
child, and sibling relationships.
One example of a more complex
relationship is something like this
controls that.
In this case, we have a button which
controls whether a particular part of
the page is visible or hidden in
the form of the disclosure widget.
And ARIA can make part of the page live,
that is inform assistive technology
right away when they change.
In this case,
we have an alert which a screen reader
might choose to immediately speak to
the user interrupting
whatever else they're doing.